[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24
consacrait à la hausse des prix à la
consommation qui touche le monde entier
aux etats unis l'inflation est au plus
haut depuis 40 ans l'inflation a atteint
7% en 2021 les républicains reprochent
du coup à joba éden une politique
inflationniste avec trop de dépenses et
fustige ce qu'ils appellent live by
deunff les jeunes même constat dans les
pays émergents où les prix de
l'alimentation explose en turquie la
hausse des prix est de 40% le président
r 2 one est qualifié de pompier pyromane
en europe l'inflation atteint 5% au mois
de décembre dans la zone euro son plus
haut niveau en 25 ans l'impact social
est déjà très fort au kazakhstan par
exemple la révolte a commencé avec
l'explosion du prix du gaz aux
etats-unis joe biden chute dans les
sondages et en france en pleine campagne
électorale le pouvoir d'achat devient la
première préoccupation des français
alors comment expliquer une telle
flambée des prix mondial cela va-t-il
durer quel est l'impact sur les
populations quel est l'impact politique
joe biden doit-il revoir sa politique
économique et en europe à quoi peut-on
s'attendre
on en parle avec mes invités jamais côté
line rifaï bonsoir line chroniqueuse
économie france 24 avec nous également
par skype benjamin coriat économiste
membre des économistes atterrés hauteur
du bien commun le climat et le marché
réponse à jean tirole 7 aux éditions les
liens qui libèrent bonsoir benjamin
coriat est bienvenue
alexandre kateb est également avec toi
alexandre kateb économiste spécialiste
des pays émergents hauteur de les
économies arabes en mouvement j'entends
que vous m'entendez c'est aux éditions
de boeck bienvenue alexandre
nous allons avoir également direct de
dakar sarah sakho notre correspondante
france 24 donc qui sera avec nous
également dans ce débat on va démarrer
pour justement bien cadrer la situation
bien cadrer le débat avec les états unis
les états unis ce chiffre on l'a appris
hier soir 7% d'inflation en 2021 c'est
le chiffre le plus élevé aux états unis
depuis 1982 hors énergie et alimentation
la progression s'élève à 5 5 % selon les
chiffres publiés dont qui hier par le
bureau of labor statistics
alors que alors que les salaires eux
n'ont augmenté que de 4,7 pour cent en
un an benjamin coriat je voudrais
commencer par vous comment expliquer une
telle hausse des prix aux états unis
benjamin coriat comment expliquer une
telle hausse des prix aux etats-unis
est-ce que vous m'entendez
à
kateb alexandre kateb les pays émergents
je disais qu'il y avait le même constat
les pays émergents les prix agricoles
qui ont augmenté d'environ 45% en
moyenne depuis le début de la pandémie
et l'alimentation d'ailleurs ça pèse
lourd dans les budgets des ménages
comment l'expliquez-vous alexandre kateb
que dans les pays émergents également il
ya une flambée des prix
il ya un petit problème de son avec
benjamin koré alexandre kateb pauline
rifai on va démarrer par vous justement
alors une inflation humble avis très
forte aux états unis dans les pays
émergents est également en europe la
zone euro l'inflation en décembre a
atteint 5% par rapport à décembre 2020
là aussi c'est son plus haut niveau oui
alors on va partir sur cette vision
globale cette inflation vous l'avez dit
elle touche la zone euro on est à un
plus haut niveau depuis la création
d'une union monétaire également aux
états unis vous l'avez dit plus forte
inflation en 40 ans une situation qui
s'explique par la l'économie post
confinement on peut pas déjà dit repose
trop vite puisqu'on voit une reprise
épidémique au niveau mondial mais post
confinement on a assisté à un arrêt
brutal de l'activité économique en 2020
une reprise très rapide en 2021 et cette
reprise elle s'est accompagnée d'une
demande qui a augmenté très fortement
d'une offre qui n'a pas pu suivre
plusieurs raisons à cela d'abord donc il
ya eu une demande très forte sur
l'énergie on l'a vu la flambée des prix
de l'énergie alors ça démarre et passa
suivi donc ses venues notamment des prix
de la flambée des prix de l'énergie
d'ailleurs si on regarde en europe la
grande partie de l'inflation elle vient
de l'énergie une hausse des prix de 26%
en descente pour l'énergie alors que
d'autres bien augmenter mais beaucoup
moins et puis d'autres bien russie sont
confrontées à des pénuries on parle
aussi de rupture de chaîne
d'approvisionnement au niveau mondial de
problèmes de transport au niveau mondial
de pénurie dit surenchérissant fait les
prix c'est ça qu'il faut bien expliquer
ligne justement parce que ces transports
sont plus chers du coup ça a un impact
direct sur les prix à la consommation et
qu'il n'y a plus suffisamment de place
sur les navires qui transportent les
marchandises l'énergie coûte plus cher
pour le transport de marchandises dans
les usines qui sont dans les pays à bas
coût notamment il ya eu des confinement
puisque ces pays étaient moins vacciner
et donc il ya eu une production qui n'a
pas suivi il ya des pénuries de main
d'oeuvre hocine lié aussi à des du
personnel qui restait à la maison
confiné où qui restait à la maison pour
garder les enfants qui n'avaient pas
école donc il ya eu tout un tas de
raisons liées à la reprise post pandémie
qui explique aussi cette hausse des prix
une demande qui augmente une offre qui
n'arrivent pas à suivre pour une
multitude de raisons alors je ne sais
pas si vous voulez qu'on revient tout de
suite sur la zone euro je pense que
alexandre kateb nous entends alexandre
kateb spécialisé pays émergents
justement une drague sur votre réaction
face à non on me vient de ma forme et
qu'on ne nous entend toujours pas en
revanche nous avons sarah sa coke est
avec nous donc en direct de dakar ça je
sais que vous êtes à un marché parce que
on parlait des pays émergents mais
également en afrique de l'ouest les pays
les prix flambent et en l'occurrence on
voit l'impact sur les marchés
oui bien sûr stéphanie tout est cher
voilà ce que nous ont dit les personnes
à qui nous avec qui nous avons discuté
ici au grand marché du centre-ville
dakarois alors il parle du prix des
légumes + 50 % le kg de patates ces
derniers mois le chou la carotte une
dame m'a dit il y à certains légumes que
nous n'osons plus touché les gens
explique changer les recettes vous savez
le plat national le riz au poisson sa
compagne de toutes une gamme de légumes
est bien certain n'achète que quelques
légumes pour décorer ce riz et il y en a
d'autres qui n'arrive même plus à faire
donc assez de quantité pour la famille
élargie puisque les gens ici en général
quand il cuisine cuisine en grande
quantité vivent en communauté donc
situation difficile tout est cher
vraiment c'est tout le monde s'accorde
pour dire cela alors les dakarois sont
habitués à ce que les plis les prix
fluctuent sur les marchés selon les
saisons en période de fêtes par exemple
mais tout le monde s'accorde à dire que
cette année et bien cela est ressenti de
manière beaucoup plus importante alors
autre signe de l'inflation c'est
vraiment l'explosion et je pèse mes mots
du prix des loyers à dakar le secteur
avait publié le secteur de l'immobilier
vais publier un chiffre il ya quelques
temps plus 250 % en vingt ans et une
hausse qui continue donc augmenté au
même rythme les gens n'arrivent tout
simplement plus à se loger alors comment
font-ils mais ils se déplacent ils vont
beaucoup plus loin ou alors il reste
n'arrive pas à s'installer par exemple
les jeunes ménages les jeunes
travailleurs c'est la galère c'est
vraiment le mot avec à la clé évidemment
une perte du pouvoir d'achat une perte
de la qualité de vie merci beaucoup
sarah sakho donc en direct de dakar line
un mot sur l'europe puisque on n'a
toujours pas nos invités on a un petit
poème de son avec benjamin coriat et
alexandre kateb dans la zone euro alors
on en n'est pas justement à ces chiffres
que vient de dévoiler sa race a qu à
dakar mais tout de même en décembre elle
a atteint 5% par rapport à décembre 2020
et ça c'est aussi son plus haut niveau
depuis le début de l'union monétaire oui
un plus haut niveau depuis le début de
monnaies de l'union monétaire alors que
pendant des années souvenez-vous la zone
euro peiné à avoir un peu d'inflation en
2015 même il ya eu la mise en place de
la planche à billets le quantitative
easing ou l'assouplissement quantitatif
justement pour créer un peu d'inflation
parce qu'il était plus tôt face aux
risques de déflation qui est beaucoup
plus dangereux pour l'économie est
aujourd'hui donc la situation s'inverse
subitement avec cette reprise économique
post confinement on se retrouve avec une
inflation très forte à cette inflation
en zone euro elle ne touche pas tous les
pays de la même manière on voit ici
c'est 5% si la moyenne sur un an mois de
décembre 2021 mais si on compare les
pays de la zone euro on voit que
certains sont beaucoup plus touchés que
d'autres par exemple c'est le cas de
l'allemagne l'allemagne qui a une sorte
de traumatisme avec l'inflation avec les
années 20 avec les adhérents la section
comment elle est aujourd'hui confrontée
à une inflation qui qui est assez forte
5,7 pour sont allés au dessus de la
moyenne de la zone euro
d'autres pays sont en dessous de cette
moyenne de la zone euro même si
l'inflation est également forte vous
voyez 4 2% en italie 3 4% en france
selon justement l' indice des prix à la
consommation harmonisé par eurostat qui
permet les comparaisons alors il ya des
différences entre pays européens il ya
des différences aussi entre les sources
de l'inflation et à l'énergie qui pèse
énormément 26 % d'augmentation des prix
de l'énergie en zone euro ça pèse
beaucoup dans l' indice des prix à la
consommation
mais il n'ya pas que mian large de
l'énergie aussi l'alimentation
donc on en parlait avec sarah notre
correspondante mais le la zone euro et
aussi donc impacté par la hausse des
prix de l'alimentation vous voyez 3,2
pour cent d'augmentation et les
européens le voit avec le prix de
certains biens alimentaires qui
augmentent fortement par exemple en
termes de matières premières il ya le
blé qui augmente énormément le blé dur
qui entre dans la fabrication des pâtes
d'où l'augmentation du prix du pain et
le prix du pain avec le blé tendre qui
augmentent également cela est notamment
dû à des raisons climatiques des
sécheresses notamment au canada qui est
le premier producteur ou un des
principaux producteurs de blé dur donc
on le voit ça se répercute ya aussi une
augmentation par exemple du prix du
beurre et cela se ressent sur le prix
des billets noise riz sur le prix de la
fameuse galette des rois où on est en
pleine saison actuellement en france
donc on cela augmente beaucoup moins que
l'énergie mais cela augmente beaucoup et
cela pèse sur le consommateur elin
justement ça devient un thème de
campagne on est en pleine campagne
présidentielle vous avez là sur
d'ailleurs avec cette nouvelle émission
qui démarre demain à eco de campagne en
france le pouvoir d'achat est le premier
sujet des français de préoccupation des
français est alors souvent au cours des
campagnes présidentielles ça a été un
des principaux voir le premier sujet de
préoccupation milan d'autant plus
aujourd'hui qu'on est dans un contexte
inédit depuis de nombreuses années d'une
inflation qui accélère à 3,4 pour cent
si on prend le chiffre harmonisé au
niveau européen donc sur un an 3,4 pour
cent en décembre 2021 si on revient en
arrière en décembre 2020 tenez vous bien
le taux était à 0 % l'inflation était
nulle et d'un coup en une année on est à
3 24% pour leur sens et les français
leur sens est une préoccupation majeure
quand ils font leurs courses ils
ressentent cela les français les plus
modestes le ressentent aussi parce
qu'ils consacrent une part beaucoup plus
importante de leur budget à la
consommation courante ils ressentent
cela davantage nous des mesures du goût
en cette période électorale pour
justement limiter cette hausse des prix
ou plutôt cette perte de pouvoir d'achat
pour les consommateurs le chèque énergie
l'indemnité inflation en fin d'année
dernière donc des mesures mais aussi les
candidats à l'élection ce s'empare du
sujet pour faire des propositions
certaines propositions concerne
l'augmentation du salaire minimum
d'autres concernent la baisse des
charges ou des cotisations patronales
sur les bas salaires donc il ya une
multitude de propositions qui sont
faites pour justement répondre à la
préoccupation des français concernant le
pouvoir d'achat alexandre kateb
économiste spécialisé pays émergents
m'entends genre au monde dit que non
tant est ce que vous entendez vous merci
alexandre alors justement on parlait des
pays émergents et on a vu donc à dakar
donc pays africains donc là aussi donc
elle vraiment des prix à l'alimentation
qui flambent les prix agricoles ont
augmenté de 45% en moyenne depuis le
début de la pandémie pourquoi alexandre
et m
les prix agricoles ont augmenté comme
tous les prix parce que la pandémie a eu
un impact considérable sur les chaînes
d'approvisionnement et sur les chaînes
de distribution et ça a également touché
le secteur agro alimentaire et agricole
à cela s'ajoutent d'autres facteurs
comme le roman très fort des prix de
l'énergie après sa chute en 2020 après
la chute du pétrole le prix du pétrole a
rebondi et avec lui sa entraîné un
rebond de toutes les matières premières
agricoles notamment qui utilisent de
l'énergie comme intrant donc ça peut
s'expliquer par ces différentes raisons
est-ce que ça va durer alexandre kateb
alors
d'après d'après les agences officielles
on devrait assister à un tassement de
cette hausse des prix
mais ça pourrait prendre quelques
trimestres c'est à dire qu'on va pas
s'attendre à ce que les prix baissent
avant
2023 au plus tôt et donc il ya une
période un peu difficile à gérer qui est
cette période où les prix vont continuer
encore
à augmenter sur leur lancée en tout cas
rester à un niveau relativement élevé
mais on peut dire qu'on entre dans une
période inflationniste en tout cas
pendant les années qui viennent dans les
pays émergents c'est pas c'est pas
certain c'est pas certain parce que là
on est vraiment encore la tête dans le
guidon si j'ose dire avec l'attendait me
et ses conséquences immédiates et cette
inflation qu'on constate aujourd'hui est
en grande partie liée à ces
développements qui sont sans précédent
et compris pour les chaînes
d'approvisionnement mondiales donc on
peut aussi assister à un retour à la
normale d'ici deux trois ans d'autant
plus que en fait là la hausse des prix a
eu un impact positif dans la mesure où
elle à stimuler l'investissement et
notamment l'investissement dans ce
qu'ils aient tous les produits
manufacturés dans les prix ont augmenté
et dans la demande a augmenté et on
devrait constater en fait l'impact
bénéfique de cet investissement dans les
années qui viennent y compris en chine
et y compris dans les pays occidentaux
donc il n'y a pas que des points
négatifs
benjamin coriat est-ce que vous
m'entendez oui je vous entends
magnifique benjamin comment expliquer
une telle hausse des prix aux états unis
j'avais démarré l'émission part cela
parce que le chiffre est tombé hier soir
7% d'inflation en 2021 c'est un plus
haut comment l'expliquer aux états unis
écoutez je crois que c'est une surprise
pour beaucoup de monde à ce niveau là
hein donc c'est pas très facile à
expliquer bon en tout cas les éléments
dont on dispose
c'est que la politique extrêmement
laxiste de la fed pendant très longtemps
conjugués aux plans de byden dont il
semble bien quand même que il n'a pas
été extrêmement bien calibrée du point
de vue
du point de vue du timing si je peux
dire et qui est très important puisque
c'est de 2400 milliards de dollars
bon venant sur une situation que
maintenant on connaît bien et qui est
mondial de rupture de chaîne
d'approvisionnement
de compétition pour les matières
premières parce qu'il ya des pays qui
continuent à croître
relativement vite et puis il ya des pays
qui ont un peu davantage que nous
échapper à la crise en particulier en
asie et qu'elle se précipitent sur les
matières premières pour alimenter leur
appareil productif bon voilà les
éléments dont on dispose mais je veux
dire il faut pas
comment dire laisser supposer que
c'était évident une telle explosion de
l'inflation si c'est vrai problème
justement benjamin coriat y avait déjà
un débat aux états unis depuis un an
avec notamment l'ancien conseiller larry
summers qui disait que les plans de
relance de joe biden y en a deux qui
sont passés un le troisième pour
l'instant été retoquée au sénat allait
avoir un impact inflationniste alors que
d'autres disaient non non ça n'aura pas
d'impact un pc impressionniste est ce
que finalement larry summers ou même
d'ailleurs l'ancien chef économiste du
fmi également olivier blanchard alertait
sur cet impact inflationniste ils ont
raison effectivement le plan de relance
a un impact inflationniste aux états
unis oui je pense que dans l'immédiat on
peut pas on peut pas vraiment leur
donner tort il y avait eu si vous voulez
il ya deux aspects sur les plans de
relance de baden le fait qu' il était au
fond justifié à la fois pour réparer les
infrastructures à la fois pour réparer
le tissu social etc
bon moi je suis de ceux que c'est le cas
1 alors ensuite le moment dans lequel
ils ont été lancés et le niveau auquel
ils ont été lancés faisait davantage
débat et on peut pas dire que ce qui
mettait en garde sur le fait qu' il
fallait bien veiller au timing et au
volume
avait à mes torts je crois que sur le
fond il avait raison
d'alerté et une partie de l'inflation à
laquelle on assiste est sans doute lié à
ça encore une fois il faut rester
prudent sur l'interprétation parce que
c'est une c'est une vraie surprise on
l'attendait pas à ce niveau là vous
l'attendez pas ce niveau-là et joe biden
non plus d'ailleurs qui chute dans les
sondages d'ailleurs en conséquence parce
qu'effectivement l'inflation un impact
social on l'a vu elle accroît la
pauvreté mais elle a aussi un impact
politique et on va le voir justement en
turquie on va retrouver notre
correspondant ludovic de foucault en
turquie alors la politique du président
r doan a un impact alors pour le coup on
peut le dire bien inflationnistes
puisque il ya une flambée des prix qui
se rapproche de 40 % la hausse du prix
du pain et de 54% en turquie recep
tayyip erdogan a voulu la croissance à
tout prix finalement ludovic est ce
qu'on peut dire que c'est devenu un
sorte de pompier pyromane 1ère doan la
monnaie qui dégringole
bonsoir c'est fanny bonsoir à tous
erdogan pompier pyromane écouter
pompiers on peut probablement le dire
parce qu'il a quand même décidé de
réévaluer le salaire minimum il a
augmenté de 50 % il s'est dit prêt ces
derniers jours à une nouvelle
réévaluation si la situation l'exigé en
juillet il a aussi donné un coup de
pouce décider d'un coup de pouce aux
retraités aux pensions privées en
injectant de l'argent au public mais il
faut dire que les effets de ces mesures
sera très certainement limité par les
hausses importantes des prix de
l'électricité du gaz de l'essence des
transports publics plus 125% de factures
d'électricité 1 pour certains ménages en
turquie quand même et puis pyromane
parce que au-delà du contexte
international que vous avez rappelé avec
line et vous inviter la raison
principale qui existe qui explique la
situation actuelle en turquie et
l'inflation galopante c est la politique
monétaire voulue par le président turc
la banque centrale turque sous la
pression présidentielle a décidé depuis
septembre dernier
d'abaisser de 500 points son taux
d'intérêt directeur et cela a
considérablement affaibli la monnaie
nationale la livre turque qui a perdu
plus de 45% de sa valeur face au dollar
sur 2021 rsa conduit mécaniquement à
l'inflation donc officiellement + 36 %
d'augmentation des prix en décembre 2021
par rapport à décembre de l'année
précédente c'est à dire l'augmentation
la plus importante enregistrée en
turquie ces 19 dernières années et on
observe aujourd'hui que les turcs eux
mêmes ne font pas au plus confiance dans
leur monnaie nationale 60 % des dépôts
bancaires en turquie sont soit en
dollars soit en euros alors est-ce que
ça aura des conséquences politiques pour
le président c'est l'agression supposée
ali dénonce les plus importants pour les
ménages
exactement les postes de dépenses les
plus importants pour les ménages turc
c'est
le logement l'alimentation le transport
et ce sont précisément les postes de
dépenses qui ont explosé ces derniers
mois particulièrement ces dernières
semaines et les ménages les plus touchés
sont les ménages modestes les classes
populaires les classes moyennes
inférieures qui constitue
traditionnellement le coeur de
l'électorat de la cap et donc oui il y à
un risque politique évident pour le
parti présidentiel avant les élections
qui auront lieu ou qui sont censées
avoir lieu en tout cas en juin 2003
merci ludovic un donc en direct
d'istanbul alexandre kateb c'était
pourtant l'hyperinflation me semble-t-il
qui avait d'ailleurs porté hors douane
au pouvoir en 2000 la turquie c'est
quand même assez incroyable ce qui se
passe il a limogé lui trois gouverneurs
de la banque centrale alors que deux
tiers des dépôts départ ils sont en
devises qui a une inflation importée
extraordinaire la turquie aujourd'hui
est extrêmement fragilisée
fait on peut dire que la politique
économique du président erdogan est très
hétéro dox dans la mesure où
ils prétendaient que la baisse des taux
d'intérêt en fait se traduirait par une
baisse de l'inflation ce qui va à
contre-courant de toutes les théories
économiques établies et en l'occurrence
le résultat est désastreux donc mon
objectif c'était peut-être de soutenir à
tout prix la croissance et le pouvoir
d'achat mais en réalité le résultat est
l inverse et l'erreur
erdogan sait que la turquie est un pays
qui dépend beaucoup des financements
extérieurs notamment des financements à
très court terme pour sa balance
courante et est du coup en fait c'est
cette défiance des investisseurs
vis-à-vis de l'économie turque a
accéléré la dégringolade de la monnaie
et les difficultés de financement qui
vont avec dans un cercle vicieux
contrairement à des économies
relativement fermé l'économie turque est
très ouverte et donc toute mesure
de politique monétaire a un impact
direct sur
le taux de change est donc il peut s'en
sortir est ce que la turquie peut
retrouver un taux
d'inflation à peu près normale retrouvez
c'était quand même une puissance
régionale puissance économique il faut
s'en sortir mais ça va passer
probablement par des solutions
relativement douloureuse
par une reprise en main en fait au
niveau de la politique monétaire et une
politique de rigueur budgétaire et je ne
suis pas certain qu aujourd'hui le
président erdogan est créé à cette
éventualité mais ça s'imposera quoiqu'il
quoi qui ne veuille parce que c'est là
les les faits sont têtus et est
aujourd'hui
ce présidence art aux murs des déchets
et des réalités économiques et sociales
il va devoir revenir effectivement sur
sur sa politique lié n'a justement
difficultés économiques et sociales
l'impact social bien sûr de l'inflation
c'est la pauvreté c'est également
l'accroissement des inégalités on a vu
au soudan d'ailleurs que la révolte a
démarré avec la hausse du prix du pain
au kazakhstan plus récemment c'était la
hausse des prix du gaz donc
effectivement il ya une contestation
sociale qui va directement avec
l'inflation puisqu'elle entraîne la
pauvreté oui parce que mécaniquement
l'inflation elle touche je le disais
tout à l'heure les ménages les plus
modestes les plus pauvres et pas
seulement dans les pays en développement
dans les pays pauvres mais partout
pourquoi cela parce que les ménages les
plus modestes sont ceux qui vont
consacrer la part la plus importante de
leur budget soit on parle en économie de
propension marginale à consommer c'est
eux qui ont cette proportion marginale à
consommer ou sa part du budget la plus
importante consacrée à la consommation
parfois il n'épargne pas du tout et donc
dès que les prix augmentent les prix de
l'alimentation les prix de l'énergie les
prix des logements ils sont directement
touchés et il n'arrive plus à joindre
les deux bouts ils sont touchés par
d'une part là certains tombent dans la
pauvreté les plus modestes et puis les
inégalités s'accroissent pourquoi parce
que les ménages les plus riches sont
moins touchés eux peuvent épargner
auront plus de marge de manoeuvre pour
faire face à ces hausses de prix et sont
donc moins concerné par cela benjamin
coriat l'inflation ça entraîne des
contestations sociales dans les
différents pays
on vient de comprendre pourquoi ben
c'est ce qui a été c'est ce qui a été
dit par par notre invité ça touche plus
fortement les bas revenus je regardais
quelques statistiques là juste justement
pour préparer des missions et dans nos
pays c'est à dire dans les pays riches
l'allemagne la grande bretagne etc on a
des situations dans lesquelles on a
maintenant plusieurs millions de
personnes qui étaient un peu sur le fil
du rasoir et qui sont dans des
arbitrages sur se chauffer ou
s'alimenter un nom je veux dire c'est
très sérieux c'est très sérieux et pour
la raison que
les les les os d'une part touche
principalement l'énergie par ce biais
l'alimentation est le fait que des
millions de ménages qui étaient
on peut dire juste à flot ne le sont
plus ne le sont plus donc est-ce que ça
va se traduire par des mouvements
sociaux bon l'avenir le dira mais dans
tous les cas
cessé ces personnes vont devoir bouger
parce que là elle perdre pied elles
perdent pied donc on va assister à des
choses
importantes à ce niveau alexandre
catalan qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant
puisqu'on a vu l'impact social impact
politique maintenant la politique doit
reprendre le dessus pour justement
lutter contre cette inflation tous les
regards bien sûr sont tournés vers la
fed la réserve fédérale américaine la
banque centrale américaine va-t-elle ou
pas on a entendu jérôme powell cette
semaine qui a dit qu'il allait il a
promis d'agir en conséquence est-ce
qu'il va augmenter les taux d'intérêt
parce qu'on sait que ça s'il le fait ça
aussi ça aura un impact très important
dans les pays émergents bien sûr ça aura
un impact très important d'ailleurs plus
peut-être dans ces pays là qu aux etats
unis puisque
cet impact sera ressenti sur le sur les
taux d'intérêts danser dans ces
différents pays qui sont liés d'une
manière ou d'une autre à celui de la
réserve fédérale parlera par les taux de
change etc ils échangent commerciaux et
financiers et donc ça peut provoquer une
sorte de choc comme à l'époque il ya eu
le choc wolker au début des années 1980
et bien là on pourrait avoir le choc
powell alors les effets seront
différenciées parce que certains pays
émergents certains grands pays émergents
la russie par exemple anticipé ce
resserrement de la politique monétaire
et l'ont un temps mise en oeuvre avant
avant que les américains ne réagissent
et donc on peut penser que dans ces pays
là l'impact sera
relativement modérée mais mais mais dans
des pays qui ne se sont pas préparés le
cas de la turquie est tombé matic là je
pense que l'impact sera vraiment très
très négatif on bat jamin coria est-ce
que effectivement
powell donc le patron de la fed va
augmenter les taux est ce qu'on va
vraiment vers un resserrement monétaire
maintenant justement que ça fait
vraiment un moment qu'on en débat aux
états unis est-ce que c'est 7% c'est un
seuil qui fait qu' on va basculer dans
une autre politique monétaire écoutez je
pense que ce qui était prévu et annoncé
un parent par la fed est d'ailleurs par
la banque centrale européenne s'était
progressivement effectivement de
d'abandonner le laxisme monétaire et de
commencer à racheter
beaucoup moins d'actifs de manière à ce
que les bulles qui se sont constitués
puisse comment dire évoluer et se
dégonfler lentement un en essayant
d'éviter leur explosion bien cette
inflation est cette crise parce que si
vous voulez c'est très paradoxal parce
que les taux de croissance ne sont pas
mauvais ils sont même plutôt bons dans
différents pays mais ça s'accompagne de
déséquilibre de rupture d'amour d'apo
d'approvisionnement et de montée des
prix
donc cette situation nouvelle et
inattendue d'une certaine manière va
sans doute calmé les esprits 1 j'ai vu
que par exemple madame lagarde en ce qui
concerne la bce
annoncé des choses rassurantes en disant
on va pas mettre fin à notre programme
de rachat bien
là la fed ne l'a pas encore dit aussi
clairement mais très probablement ils
vont calmer le jeu est-ce que ça va
suffire ça c'est la question qui est
ouverte et c'est vrai que ça va suffire
est ce que ça ne va pas casser la
croissance paradoxalement voilà voilà
on est un peu dans une situation
de dilemme compliqué parce que
si
on diminue on essaye de diminuer la
bulle et les bulles monétaire on risque
d'accélérer
les ruptures et donc de casser la
croissance et si on continue à alimenter
comme si de rien n'était ban inflation
est bien de dire halte là donc je veux
dire le fine tuning le réglage fin
est revenu à l'ordre du jour de manière
plus prégnante que jamais line ce qu'on
craint c'est ce réglage fin justement
dont tu parles parce que ça fait un
moment on parlait plus du tout de
l'inflation il faut quand même le nord
par les pionniers et tout d'un coup là
ça revient phénomène mondial on a parlé
de l'augmentation des prix d'énergie et
là on se rencontre vous l'avez bien
expliqué que ça rentre ça rentre
vraiment dans les différents secteurs de
l'économie et que ça devient une vraie
problématique lorsqu'on craint que ce
qui a été mentionné à maintes reprise
par les analystes de marché notamment
ces derniers mois ces dernières semaines
aussi c'est la crainte du retour de la
stagflation c'est à dire une stagnation
économique et une forte inflation c'est
le phénomène qu'on a vu dans les années
70 notamment dans de nombreux pays
avancés où l'inflation a accéléré en
même temps la croissance n'allait pas
assez vite et on était dans ce n'est pas
ce que c'était ambitieux
là alors au cours des dernières semaines
j'ai eu l'occasion de discuter avec de
nombreux économistes qui disaient non il
ne faut pas avoir peur de cela puisque
l'inflation est certes là mais elle ne
devrait pas durer au-delà d'un certain
temps au delà de l'année 2022 en tout
cas ce qu'on disait cette dernière
semaine là et les fondamentaux qui
expliquait la très faible inflation dans
les économies avancées en tout cas sont
toujours là on est tous et qui cosigne
croissance qui n'est pas très forte on
est face à une démographie qui reste fut
relativement faible dans ces pays là on
est à façade et au départ qui sont
importants et donc si on regarde
vraiment le long terme ont l'idée d'une
stagnation séculaire d'une croissance
base d'une inflation qui ne décolle pas
ils sont toujours là une fois que le
choc du de la cobi 19 serait passé donc
ça veut dire quoi
alexandre kateb pour vous justement ce
cette finesse qu'il va falloir utiliser
en politique économique en politique
monétaire est ce qu'il va falloir que
cette politique monétaire s'accompagne
de restrictions également du côté
budgétaire comment ça va se passer
dans l'idéal il faut trouver le bon
policier policy mix effectivement entre
la politique monétaire et la politique
budgétaire dès jeudi rex qui est ce qui
est important pour moi la variable
principal il faut surveiller ses les
taux à long terme parce que c'est ce
sont ces tola qui conditionnent en fait
le financement des projets
d'investissement et donc in fine et la
croissance économique les taux à court
terme impact beaucoup plus les acteurs
financiers
et donc leur désistement justement les
taux les taux à long terme aujourd'hui
restent relativement stables en dépit
des annonces de resserrement monétaire
parce que les d'une part les
anticipations d'inflation à long terme
restent ancrés à un niveau relativement
faible donc là on peut dire que soit
c'est un succès de la politique menée
par la fed et les autres banques
centrales soit c'est parce que nés y
aller les facteurs démographiques etc ac
évoqué line et qui compte qu'ils aillent
pas une croissance structurellement
faible à long terme et que le la menace
déflationniste l'emportent sur la menace
inflationniste en réalité mais je pense
que globalement ça montre qu'aujourd'hui
la situation reste reste sous contrôle à
ceux à ce niveau là il faudra la
surveiller bien entendu parce que si on
s'aperçoit que l'inflation persistent
beaucoup plus que ce qui est prévu et
annoncé par les différentes banques
centrales à ce moment là les
anticipations pourrait aussi être
révisée à la hausse et dans ce cas les
taux d'intérêt à long terme pourraient
également remonté benjamin coriat bon on
a vu pendant la dernière crise
financière que les banques centrales
étaient au rendez vous qu'elle avait
évité justement le pire est ce que là on
peut faire confiance justement à ces
banques centrales à la fed à la banque
centrale européenne à la banque de
londres aussi parce que l'angleterre
connaît également à très très fort taux
d'inflation
pour justement contrôler la situation
je pense que évidemment elles vont
s'efforcer de faire en sorte que le
passage soit le moins douloureux
possible mais il ya deux éléments qui
tempère on va dire le relatif optimisme
mais disons eva l'évaluation
pas trop peu inquiète si je peux dire
qui a été fait ces deux éléments c'est
que
d'un côté
quand on dit les conditions pour éviter
la stagflation ou en tout cas pour
revenir à une croissance
non inflationniste sont réunis
moi j'en suis pas convaincu je ne suis
pas convaincu pourquoi pour deux raisons
la peau et ses salles à peu les deux
éléments qui tempère
on va dire une vision qui serait
béatement optimiste ou simplement
optimiste le premier élément c'est que
la mondialisation des échanges qui était
à la grande base de la lutte contre
l'inflation parce que on avait des prix
des plus bas qui arrivait de partout
dans le monde et sur tous les marchés et
en particulier des états unis et de
pardon de lâcher une machine c'est fini
ça c'est fini ça veut dire que la guerre
commerciale entre les états unis et la
chine les différentes guerres qui ce
commercial qui se prépare la taxe
carbone aux frontières
qui va se faire d'une manière ou d'une
autre d'une manière ou d'une autre
va ralentir et pour partie bloquer
les flux des changes donc je veux dire
cet élément de tempérance
la globalisation à mon avis elle a eu
quand même beaucoup d'effets négatifs
mais elle avait 7 à fait positif là
c'est qu'elle tenait les prix bas bien
mais ça n'a plus existé et donc a priori
vous vous pensez qu'il va y avoir un
maintien des prix élevés
moi je pense que ceci
tempèrent l'optimisme qu'on peut avoir
c'est à dire que ce facteur perturbateur
là à savoir une globalisation
entravé ne permet va pas permettre un
retour aisé ça c'est la première chose
et la deuxième chose c'est les taux
d'intérêt alors effectivement des taux
d'intérêt sur le long terme pour le
moment n'ont pas encore beaucoup bougé
mais
les comment dire la dette qui pour les
pays riches en tout cas était jusqu'à
présent gratuites à cesser de mettre un
l'état lit maintenant elle est à plus de
1 % de spread la france est repassé en
territoire positif
et puis j'ai bu un petit papier qui
disait que en allemagne on était en émoi
parce que on risque et on avait failli
repasser en niveau positif bien ça n'a
pas été le cas mais comment dire voilà
ça c'est le deuxième élément qui
amène à considérer que les choses
peuvent être plus difficiles que prévu
en tout cas la fla sion donc pour
reprendre le titre cette émission c'est
véritablement le défi 2022 à vous
entendre merci beaucoup benjamin coriat
d'avoir été avec nous merci alexandre
kateb merci à sa race à commercy à
ludovic de foucauld merci line line
rifaï donc l'émission ça démarre demain
et côte campagne ça sera à 17h15 sur
france 24 merci à vous tous deux ans vit
et reste avec nous
[Musique]